welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and thor love and thunder populates
the mcu with a wider mix of oddballs but
leaves a few seats unoccupied at the
orgy for those feeling like that
ampersand between the love and the
thunder originally had a lot more room
for oh say another half hour of gore
butchering more gods you ain't wrong we
are learning more and more of deleted
scenes and rejected concepts fully
removed sequences and now with
increasing calls for a director's cut to
be released i'm gonna break down
everything we know that was left out of
this movie and what we've learned about
this rumored director's cut oh by the
way the best way to support new
rockstars is to check out our worthy a
love shirt on newrockstarsmerch.com
worthy of love because you are and this
video is brought to you by squarespace
the all-in-one platform for building
your brand more on them later for being
a god butcher you don't actually see
gore murder that many gods uh uh excuse
me this god butcher will be uh
butchering some gods won't he hello
is anyone there i really hate that man
the only one we see gore kill is rapu in
the opening scene and then off screen he
kills falagar he tries to kill sif but
leaves her behind i guess to send a
message that guardian's distress call
map mentions over a thousand other kills
including three corpses hanging from
hooks from inside rubik's comics art the
head of another god the corpse of
another we also know from king yakan's
line that gore killed the gods of the
indigarians as well but it has now been
confirmed from christian bale and take
away tg that they did shoot several gore
murder scenes christian bale recently
being quoted saying that they left gold
on the cutting room floor really really
creepy stuff but we know this would have
included at least one scene with jeff
goldblum is the grand master from thor
ragnarok peter dinklage as itri from
infinity war and lena heady as an
unspecified goddess now we did see a
skeleton of some giant creature that i
speculated might have been part of
etry's race but this skeleton seems like
it's been dead for years maybe left up
chained for decades and since gore has
really been on this slaughter recently
it doesn't seem like it was a recent
kill i guess it could have been one of
thanos's victims since he killed the
other net of valyrian dwarves i'm just
not sure but killing off the grand
master might have closed too many doors
in the mcu he is considered an elder of
the universe alongside his brother the
collector tennelier tavon whose fate
remains unknown last we saw of him was a
reality stone illusion cast by thanos
and infinity war i'm dying to know what
goddess lena heady was gonna be playing
she might have played the true forms of
one of the statues we saw in the chamber
like infinity or death like think about
it cersei lannister would make an
amazing mistress death of the mcu now
remember when thor brought gore's threat
to zeus's attention zeus said that guy
he killed a couple of low-level gods eh
boohoo so it confirms that zeus knew
about these victims but did not care now
there was one greek god that was
credited in the movie's credits whom i
had some trouble spotting in this
chamber actress priscilla doherty
credited as artemis god it's just kind
of inconsistent which gods in the scene
get credited and which don't but artemis
being credited might indicate that
artemis had some bigger scene that was
cut she might have actually been one of
those victims on the guardian star map
screen it's its artemis is zeus's
daughter that would make zeus even more
apathetic and cruel and further justify
why dionysus another one of zeus's kids
was such a suck-up now another major
deleted scene was jane foster's power up
the theatrical cut never shows the
moment jane transforms into the mighty
thor we just see the broken pieces of
mjolnir stirring and then we cut away
and jane is just revealed later in the
middle of the battle after some time has
passed with her heroics at new asgard
but we know the production shot this
scene from set footage natalie portman
was on a crane and wire apparatus being
raised off the ground while she was
standing beside the mule near pedestal
her body flailing around excluding this
transition makes jane's arrival
mid-battle more of a surprise i suppose
more of a visually strategic reveal
keeping the viewer's eye focused just on
the broken hammer first before inviting
scrutiny on jane's physique but it's
also just possible that the production
hit its limit with the vfx now if you
hate your job or maybe you hate not
having a job then maybe you can make
2022 the year you start your own
business squarespace is the all-in-one
platform to build a beautiful online
presence for that new business you want
a website that projects that you know
what you're doing and squarespace does
just that squarespace is a bunch of
great features to help your business be
successful you can present members only
gated content create email campaigns or
add online booking for appointments or
sessions all from the squarespace
interface i really dig the analytics
section of a squarespace website where
you can dig into what's working and what
you should be doing more of head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com new rockstars to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain then squarespace.com new
rockstars for 10 off your first purchase
of a website or a domain jane's
transformation would have been a complex
vfx shot one specifically tricky to
balance with the emotions of jane's
cancer stricken body powering up into a
cosmic god like that kind of moment
can't really be played for laughs room
for a gross shock value the way
characters hulking out look like but it
also can't really look cheap they would
have to have nailed this perfectly and
maybe at the end of the day they just
couldn't really pull it off because
tiger with tt and tessa thompson joked
in another video with vanity fair how
they actually ran out of time to perfect
korg in another scene and recently you
may have seen how some bfx artists who
worked on other marvel titles have begun
to speak out how the studio is putting
too much strain on them to fully master
sequences just for the studio to change
their minds last minute so maybe in this
case taika just scrapped the scene it's
just interesting to hear them talk about
how much this film was figured out on
the fly weirdly on these big movies
everything takes
so much longer to shoot the main thing
on this was that we just kept
experimenting with the story and trying
to figure out like the best narrative
new dialogue and it would come back and
we just wanted like one more angle just
someone explaining oh this is what the
villain wants yeah and from that it
sounds like gore's plan changed in this
movie in the theatrical cut gore kidnaps
the children of asgard and takes them to
the shadow realm and then they end up
with him in the chamber of the cosmic
entities but we don't really see these
kids on a shadow realm planet or really
know why they're with gore when he
approaches eternity so i'm guessing
there was some other removed portion of
the movie's second act in which gore
either didn't kidnap the kids or really
i think it's more likely the dude just
continued his killing spree you think
about it a serial killer like gore the
god butcher just makes more sense that
we would spend the second act of that
film with him killing higher and higher
profile gods every movie with a serial
killer whether it's seven or the dark
knight that's what the killer does in
the second act he kills now much of this
town hall scene actually had to be
reconfigured it sounds like like think
about it it's pretty weird we don't see
where jane goes anytime she blasts off
and tessa thompson even pointed out a
weird take that taika kept in without
him realizing it see this shot when i go
it's because it used to be when he would
wake up that was my reality
but you just left it there randomly
doesn't make any sense but i love it now
moving on to some other rejected ideas
we learned from concept art mission to
the odd study of australia that
originally russell crowe was considered
to play the devil instead of zeus art
shows him as a hooked devil holding the
severed human foot that he was munching
on now this wouldn't necessarily be
mephisto this isn't really what mepisto
looks like not all devils look the same
this just kind of looks like a general
satanic figure we also know from the
trailer that there were a few deleted
one-off takes like that shot of valkyrie
licking gold blood off her sword really
bummed that didn't make it in the movie
i love that shot even if it does like
freak me out don't lick blades taika
also admitted in interviews that they
planned to work in more kate bush music
until stranger things stole their
thunder with running up that hill pika
said he had a sequence of mine for jane
foster said to kate bush's this woman's
work he also wanted to expand more on
abba this movie's flashback of course
includes abba's hour last summer but
taika said his idea was for thor to love
abba seeing the swedish band as a viking
band and for there to even be a music
video dance number set to abba now when
taekwo titu was asked about releasing a
director's cut or many of these deleted
scenes he told new music express that
he's not that big on director's cuts and
believes deleted scenes are deleted for
a reason you know i often think about
this about directors cuts i watch
director's cuts from a lot of other
directors they suck director's cuts are
not good you know directors need to be
controlled sometimes if i was to say
like oh you've got to watch my
director's cut it's four and a half
hours long it's not good four and a half
hours you know there's a lot of cup of
tea breaks in there you don't even have
to pause it my cut would probably have a
few more jokes or there might be a
couple of little deleted scenes the
scene is deleted because it's not good
enough to be in the film it doesn't help
the movie an interesting hot take i mean
i hear why tt that deleted scenes are
deleted for a reason they often would
not make the movie better at all but i
just cannot agree with the guy when it
comes to the director's cuts of movies
like the lord of the rings trilogy or
blade runner or aliens there's just too
many examples of great director's cuts
out there to say that they generally
suck are you crazy but then again i am
also someone who just loves to learn
everything about how the sausage gets
made to me learning all the creative
sacrifices made in movies and all the
awkward first drafts that they went
through just make me appreciate the
creative process even more i like to
demythologize filmmakers they're not
gods they're just mortals like us
artists struggling through this process
having to make impossible decisions and
the more i know about the jobs the more
i respect them as artists also i love
sausage up in sinclair's jungle may have
grossed you out but for me those chunks
of lithuanian meat packers who fell in
the bat taste so good if you're not too
grossed out follow me on instagram and
twitter at e boss follow me rockstar
subscribe to rockstars for more analysis
of everything you love thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you